I had done a TV series prior to
Halloween where I'd gotten fired but I
was one of thirteen or fourteen regulars
on a half hours one camera TV show and
if I had two lines a week that was a lot
all I remember about Halloween was that
it was a script where every single page
had the name Laurie on it so what I knew
was that it was a big part and in when I
was a young actress that kind of part
obviously it was not what I was doing I
was doing two lines here and there so to
have something where it was that kind of
complete character was kind of exciting
for me you know what was nice is that
that the roots of this were so low scale
crappy little offices in this old old
building on Cahuenga Boulevard it was
too little offices side-by-side one was
Deborah Hills one was John Carpenter's
and that was the extent of their big
production offices well Jamie came to
read for me and we picked a scene in the
script and she read it and she had her
there was an innocence and he had a
strength going on in there
and I really liked it plus the girl I
wanted for the part had turned me down
so Jamie was perfect there was an
actress who was well known or better
known than me who was also up for the
part and I remember that and I knew her
name and so like it was with me with
Debra Winger than ten years later where
every audition I would go into I'd look
at the list and Debra wingers name and
I'd be like okay well I'll just go in
anyway but I mean I knew she was going
to get it like every so I knew that this
woman probably had the the upper hand if
you will or the the you know I I figured
she would get it because she was more
well known and had more experience and
that I remember because I I I know who
she is
guess I do not remember finding that out
I don't remember any of it I remember
meeting with the costume woman talking
about Laurie and we went to JCPenney and
we basically bought back-to-school
clothes for this girl so it was like
going shopping with Laurie's mother like
we were dressing Laurie so I bought the
you know there was that skirt and then
there was the turtleneck and then the
little cardigan sweater and the
thigh-high kind of big socks and I had
had a perm when I met John but then they
decided they wanted my hair straight or
not straight but not frizzy like a perm
and so then I remember putting hot
rollers in my hair each day to get it
just you know kind of straighten out I
remember that I don't think we ever met
and rehearsed I don't think we ever had
any of that I think it was show up on
your first day you know right away we
were working there was no gentle entries
I think the first things we did if I
remember correctly was the girls walk
and talk on the street carrying the
books the car comes by speed kills that
whole sequence and then the second half
of the day was me and Tommy Doyle
meeting where I crossed the street meet
walk down the street that's the scary
house you know don't go in there and
then I go up to the door and then we
have the little scene out on the street
and then the great shot later of Michael
inside the door his POV and then Laurie
walking down the street and I remember
his the last thing we shot that day was
me walking down the street away from
Tommy Doyle singing the little song and
I remember saying to John very clearly I
remember saying so what what do you want
me to sing and he said well just you
know make up a song I said because I
don't sing really don't say and he said
well it doesn't matter it's you know
it's like an internal monologue it's not
it she's not belting a you know
country-western tune and I remember like
I okay and you know really
just making it up on the spot I wish I
had you know I told her to make up a
song so she made it up it's great and
yeah I didn't have to tell Jamie too
much she knew what she knew what to do
she was just and so instinctive and
energetic and actress I loved her you'll
do what I think about it now is it it's
incredibly poignant and I think that
must have been Debra Hill that whole
idea of a girl I would hold you close to
me so close to me just the two of us I
mean that's incredibly romantic and
dreamy and innocent and beautiful and of
course your counter pointing it with
this POV of this killer behind this I
mean it's it's just beautiful and that
was the first day all of that was day
one no I mean I saw I mean obviously I
saw Nick Castle wearing it and at the
time it was a guy in a you know cover
all one-piece a onesie we were ahead of
the game with the onesie and you know
this kind of white face you know it was
so fast and furious I really just don't
think anybody it was there he was and it
was like okay let's do this that was all
the first day I mean it was a lot of
work I would love if somebody had the
original production notes and actually
because I've heard anywhere from 17 to
21 days I think it was 17 days and so I
think it was $300,000 in 17 days so it
was fast and all I remember was that
first day and the beautiful story that
goes with that and I like telling it
because it tells you everything and it's
never happened to me again and my guess
is it will never happened and I'm
including this movie I lived with a
hairdresser named Tina Cassidy we rented
a house together in Studio City and I
finished my first day work and I came
back to this house we lived in
and the phone rang that night and Tina
said Jamie it's John Carpenter and you
know in my day and I'm sure it happens
now people get fired after their first
day of work you know the director thinks
about it goes huh now I made a mistake
so I remember like the slow walk over to
the phone and being that thing of like
and he's from Kentucky I believe he was
like hey darlin
it's John I just want to tell you how
happy I am and how fantastic you work
today and I just know it's gonna be
amazing
now that just doesn't happen you know
that doesn't happen and that was all
John Carpenter and that's how it began
Nick Castle is a friend of mine from
film school we had her all band together
we made student films together so I like
the way he moved he came from a dancer
family so he had a grace a nod grace
about it I think he just did it as a
favor to John I'm sure John just said I
need somebody be in the mass where you
do it and you know maybe got paid a
couple hundred bucks or whatever it was
I mean nobody got paid anything I think
I get paid $8,000 for the whole movie
which at the time for the lead in the
movie was $2,000 a week which I'm not
saying is nothing but I'm saying you
know plus he was free it's cheap so we
put on the costume and I said now go
from here to here that was it I would
say the reason he continues to be the
have the impact that Michael Myers has
is the simplicity of the evil that there
is the word pure evil which Donald
Pleasance
dr. Loomis says from the beginning and
the enigmatic faceless expressionless
look of Michael it projects into that
mask every terrifying image we have I
mean
we were talking this morning about this
horrible man who murdered his family and
he went on TV and you know / professed
his care and everybody says well I knew
he did it cuz of this smirk cuz
apparently he smirks I didn't see it but
I heard about it you see I think we can
put all of our fears and concerns and
knowledge that evil exists in the world
because evil exists in the world and put
it behind that mask and it can be
anywhere anytime anybody and I think
it's the simplicity of that that is
terrifying so I think that is what
indoors if I had to analyze it which of
course you know because the problem is I
can say all that you guys can all be
like wow she's really smart
that was really articulate and really
thoughtful the truth is it's a [ __ ]
William Shatner mask Jane I mean like
really like all that [ __ ] I just
said about you know it's the embodiment
of evil and it's nothing I mean it's
just horseshit because it's a William
Shatner mask that they took off all the
facial expression and spray painted it
white with a can of [ __ ] spray paint
and put him on in a you know put a guy
in the mask I mean it's just I'm talking
out my butt because the truth is I don't
know anything about why he indoors I'm
just glad he does because he's my buddy
know it's like me and my shadow I mean
where would I be without Michael Myers
you know what I was saying so I'm
grateful to him for all of his badness
[Music]